when bird box crossed my path I knew
this was a story I needed to make
because it was about family and when I
finished the film I went to my babies
and I said here mommy made this for you
and even though you can't see it into
your 21 because apparently a movie about
being a mommy is a horror film you
you see it that there isn't anything I
wouldn't do for you what does it mean to
win one of these in b-school relevant in
this field and getting the love and Burt
box with something special it's it's
really nice because when you try
something new which I did and it works
you're like big pot I'm allowed to stay
around for a couple more years but it's
been a lot tonight because I brought my
son because that story that I told
really did happen so he didn't it means
a lot to me that he can be a part of
this he's old enough to sort of see what
this is about
how's it going now that he's growing up
how are you dealing with those as you as
these boys get bigger I mean I have one
two about the same age you know like my
kids are I don't know I was just blessed
with incredible kids and I'm an
incredibly honest mom and they know
what's what but they're also brave and
they're safe and they're happy and they
get I want them to go up to be who
they're supposed to be if I can manage
that you know you know just just keep
them keep some bumpers on the side you
know that's that's all I can ask
jános having a moment he is is there any
shot that one day like you guys climb
into a bus together again or maybe it's
about 69 70 years old we'll be old we'll
be on the bus where they have that lift
for the older people and so will be an
old married couple without the walker
and it'll be about how we can get to the
old people home before curfew yeah yeah
yeah so that would be the speed it'll be
a real slow film but it you know play on
the word speed up one last thing
Internet is except obsessed right now
was setting about with someone who would
you set him up with
No
[Music]
[Applause]